at the age of seven Helen Keller was
described by family members as a little
monster
she threw temper tantrums attacked
people meant had terrible personal
habits yes within a year the deafened
blind girl had been transformed
she became teachable and that teaching
untapped a level of genius and
determination which saw her overcome her
disabilities and achieved unimaginable
success in this week's by graphics we
explore how Helen Keller beat incredible
odds to become a true inspiration to the
world
Helen Keller was born on June the 27th
1880 in Tuscumbia a small town in
northern Alabama she was a perfectly
healthy baby with the ability to see and
hear her mother Kate just 23 years old
was a pampered southern belle who doted
on her first child Helens father Arthur
a Confederate veteran of the Civil War
was 42 when his daughter was born Cates
was his second wife and he had two grown
sons from his first marriage the birth
of Helen was a relief to Katie now had a
child of our own to shower love and
attention upon Helen was a quick
developer speaking her first words at
six months and taking her first steps on
a first birthday however in February
1882 at the age of nineteen months she
became severely ill with what doctors at
the time called brain fever modern
researchers believed that she may have
had scarlet fever or possibly meningitis
whatever the cause of her illness the
local doctor was convinced that the
child would not survive
[Music]
Helen did survive that the illness had
robbed her of her hearing and her sight
her bright happy world was now filled
with silence and darkness as an adult
Helen recalled coming out of her illness
I was too young to realize what happens
when I awoke and found that all was dark
and still I suppose I thought it was
nice and I must have wondered why day
was so long coming gradually however I
got used to the silence and darkness
that surrounded me and forgot it had
ever been day for the first few months
after her illness terrified Helen would
do no more than sit in her mother's lap
and cling to her dress as Kate tried to
do her daily chores then she began to
venture out on her own
first crawling around the room and
feeling her way forward she discovered
that her hands could in a small way do
the job of her eyes helping her to
identify objects and different areas of
the house with Kate's patient assistance
Helen also developed a crude system of
communication a shake of the head for no
and nod for yes a pull on her mother's
dress for come before long she had
incorporated pantomime actions into her
vocabulary if she wanted ice cream she
would pretend she was working the
freezer while shivering her ever
attentive mother would then rush to give
her whatever she wanted Helen proved to
be a very determined Charles if she set
her mind on a task she would keep at it
until she was successful her greatest
desire was to improve her ability to
communicate with others making simple
signs with her hands was simply not
enough for her the inability to make
people understand what she was thinking
and feeling led to a level of
frustration but welled deep inside her
this led to violent outbursts of temper
including screaming Fitz and even
violent outbursts Helens temper tantrums
they terrorized the family she would
smash lanterns thrust her fist in plates
of food and pinch whoever was close by
relatives referred to the child as a
monster and strongly urged Kate enough
there to put her into an institution in
1885 Kate had a second child
Mildred baby sister for Helen with her
mother's doting attention now being
shared Helen became intensely jealous
once she knocked over Mildred Scott
causing the baby to fall out a desperate
case was at her absolute wit's end
unable to control or help Helen anymore
however she remained determined not to
send her away when Helen was six her
father learned of a doctor in Baltimore
Maryland
named Julian christen who had helped
restore sight to blind people the family
took the trip to consult with dr. Chris
Tom only to be told that there was
nothing medically that could be done to
fix Helens eyesight but the doctor did
hold out a ray of hope he told the
colors about a man who specialized in
helping deaf children to communicate his
name it was Alexander Graham Bell
although today he's best remembered as
the inventor of the telephone Bell's
passion was actually helping the deaf
Belle's mother and wife were both deaf
in fact he had met his wife Mabel when
he had taken on the job as her private
tutor teaching her through a system of
signing that he had developed the
Keller's they decided to travel to
Washington in order to meet him Helen
felt comfortable with Bell right away at
that first meeting he sat her on his
knee and handed her his pocket watch she
was delighted with the vibrations that
she felt when the watch struck the hour
Bell suggested the Kellers right to the
Perkins Institute for the blind in
Boston requesting a tutor for Helen the
Institute trained teachers you could go
out and work with deaf and blind
students the director of the Institute
looked over the list of recent graduates
settling upon his star people a 20 year
old who was herself partially blind from
suffering trachoma as a child her name
was Anne Sullivan
and Sullivan arrived at the Keller house
on March 2 the 3rd 1887 Helen stood in
the doorway as she approached the child
knew from her mother's scurried
activities that morning that something
important was happening that she didn't
yet know what the most important day I
remember in all my life is the one in
which my teacher and Mansfield Sullivan
came to me Helen could hear footsteps
approaching assuming it was her mother
she held out her hands and took the
girl's hands and pulled her in for an
embrace but when Helen realized that
this was a stranger she struggled to
break free this was the first of many
temper outbursts that Anne would be
confronted with the very next day in a
fit of rage the students knocked out one
of her teachers front teeth but Helen
was quick to realize that miss Sullivan
was not about to let the petulant child
get away with her outrageous behavior as
had been happening up until then when
the breakfast-table and Helen reached
across to grab food from Anne's plate
that she was accustomed to doing with
her family members and grabs her hands
and pushed it away this sent Helen into
a fit of rage she flopped on the floor
and exhibited a full-on tantrum Sullivan
asked the other family members to leave
the room and lock the door she then
proceeded to continue eating her
breakfast
completely ignoring Helens performance
finally the exasperated child got off
the floor and felt Fran's body to see
what she was doing when she discovered
that analysts calmly eating her food she
again began to grab at the plate but
each time and would slap her hand away
Helen then began pinching Anne's hands
something that she was allowed to do
with impunity to her family members
again and slapped the hand away
finally Helen sat back on a chair and
began eating her own food and she soon
came to the realization that Helens
family members had been enabling her
behavior she knew that to make any
progress she would have to separate the
child from her parents the Kellers
agreed to let Anne and Helen live in a
small cottage not far from the main
house and wanted Helen to think that
they had traveled a long distance from
the family so the two of them set out on
a carriage ride that unknown to Helen
circled back to the cottage Helen wasn't
happy to be packed off with a strict new
teacher she spent the first day
screaming and throwing things around the
cottage that night and had to hold Helen
down for hours just to keep her in bed
the child's strength and determination
they were incredible but Anne was just
that little bit greater as the days and
weeks passed and was able to slowly
bring Helen on
to control the change began when and
started spelling out words on Helens
park the first word was doll the finger
play intrigued Helen and she proved to
be an excellent mimic soon she was
spelling out a dozen three-letter words
with her fingers but she still didn't
know what they meant the breakthrough
came on April the 5th 1887 bad morning
and had been trying to get Helen do you
understand the differences between the
words mug and water
she took her to the water pump outside
the cottage and had the girl hold out a
mug and then work to the pump so that
water filled it and began to overflow
she then began to spell the word water
on Helens free hands suddenly the light
went off in Helens mind she later wrote
that living world awakened my soul gave
it light hope joy set it free now she
had a taste for word meanings she
couldn't get enough she wanted on to
spell out everything around her she
managed add dozens of new words to her
vocabulary
every single day as her understanding of
the world grew Helens personality began
to mellow and the temper tantrums became
less frequent she came to understand
that people would treat her with greater
empathy if she displayed a kind and
caring personality with the key to
knowledge understanding word meaning now
unlocked helen was able to learn with
amazing speed in just a few short months
she was reading books in Braille and was
no longer spelling only simple words on
to Helens pal
now she was signing portions of
Shakespeare and the Bible by the time
she was nine helen was reading the works
of such great poets as Shelley
Longfellow and Oliver Wendell Holmes
this made her far more advanced in a
literary sense than most other children
of her age and quickly came to the
realization that Helens ability to
comprehend complex ideas was highly
advanced writing a report to the
director of the Perkins School for the
Blind she spoke of Anne's
near genius level learning ability but
she added that the director must not
show the report to anyone else she
didn't want Anne to be turned into a
prodigy however the director Michael and
Agnes saw Helens story is an opportunity
for reflected glory he titled the 56th
Annual Report of the Perkins school
Helen Keller a second Laura Bridgman in
the report he embellished Helens story
making it even more irresistible to the
press before long newspapers all over
the country were writing gushing stories
the child genius he was reading
Shakespeare despite not being able to
see or hear Helens story even reached
across to Europe where Queen Victoria
was intrigued to hear of the brilliant
little deaf and blind girl by age 10
Helen Keller was an internationally
renowned figure when a policeman shot
her dog lioness the news was picked up
in the papers indeed people began
sending her money to buy another dog
Helen was reported as saying that she
didn't need a new dog but she would like
to use the money to help a poor blind
deaf and mute boy named Tommy stringer
to attends the Perkins School for the
Blind the public responded and Tommy's
tuition fees were paid for this inspired
Helen do you want to help more children
so she began writing letters to people
who were willing to donate money
by the time she was 10 years of age
Helen had not spoken a clear word in her
life but then in March of 1890 she heard
about a deafblind girl in Norway who had
learned to speak with her mouth
now she became obsessed with doing the
same thing and Sullivan knew just who
could help her and that would be Sarah
fuller the director of the Mann School
for the Deaf in Boston Massachusetts
fuller decided to teach Helen herself
she took a hold of Helens hand and
placed it over her mouth to allow the
girl to feel the movement of her lips
and tongue as she spoke
Helen and copied the motions with her
own speech organs after only an hour of
intense concentration and effort she was
able to speak her first sentence it's to
warn the sound of Helens voice however
was raspy and almost impossible to
understand her untrained vocal cords
would need a lot of practice before she
was able to make legible speech in later
years she would train for three summers
under the guidance of a famous music
teacher in order to improve her speaking
voice back home in Tuscumbia Alabama
Helen Ann continued to work on speech
developments they also developed a
method of hearing what others were
saying she would place her thumb on the
throat of the speaker her forefinger on
their lips and her middle finger on
their nose this would allow her to
translate the vibrations into sound
in November 1891 eleven-year-old Helens
and a birthday presents Michael an
agnostic direktor of the Perkins
Institute it was a short story that she
had written on her Braille slate called
the frost King an Agnes was impressed
with the quality of the prose and
published the story in the Perkins
alumini magazine Helen was overjoyed to
become a published author
but the DRI was short-lived reports
reached Tuscumbia that there was a book
in print called
the frost fairies by Margaret T can be
the story was uncannily similar to
Helens story the frost gained
accusations started to circulate that
she had plagiarized the story when this
was explained to her she was horrified
reading can bees Berg she realized the
similarities were striking but she was
adamant that she had written her own
original story the reality was that
helen had become a voracious reader she
would digest one book after another with
no thought for who had written them
ideas became jumbled in her mind and she
was unable to remember if they came from
herself or from what she had read so
when she enthusiastically produced her
story she believed that the ideas were
her own however a worker at the Perkins
Institute had indeed read the frost
fairies to her over a year before the
story simply became lodged in her
subconscious and was clearly the
inspiration for the frost king the
incident caused deep embarrassment for
Helen she wrote that day in her diary it
made us feel so bad that people thought
we had been untrue and wicked my heart
was full of Tears for I loved the
beautiful truth with my whole heart and
mind Michael and Agnes was also
humiliated by the incident he had to
print a retraction to explain the mix-up
after questioning Helen he believed that
no deliberate plagiarism was involved
but then one of his teachers reported to
him that Helen had confessed the
wrongdoing to her the truth was that
this manipulative teacher had twisted
Helens words to make her sound guilty it
was enough however for an agnostic turn
against Helen and his former star pupil
and Sullivan he set up a formal hearing
in which Helen was interrogated by an
eight-member panel it was one of the
most terrifying experiences of the
11-year olds life after a day of tough
scrutiny the panel was split down the
middle as to whether deliberate
plagiarism was involved in the ends and
agnostics but the stalemate coming down
on the side of Helen the frost King
experience haunted Helen for many years
to come whenever she wrote a sentence
from then onwards she would check it
repeatedly to make
sure that it was her own original work
in March 1893 an aunt Ellen attended the
presidential inauguration of Grover
Cleveland from there they went on to
Niagara Falls where Helen was astounded
at the power of the vibrations caused by
the massive pounding waters they then
went on to Chicago to attend the World's
Fair they were escorted by Alexander
Graham Bell who was featuring his
telephone at the Great Exhibition but
the famous deafblind girl who had
conquered her handicaps was just as much
a draw cart as the renowned inventor the
exhibition which featured exhibits from
all over the world
thrilled Helen she was the only one of
the millions of visitors he was allowed
to run her hands over the exhibits this
gave her a far greater appreciation of
the world around her than anything she
had read in books wedding her appetite
to learn more at the age of 16 Helen
began studying at the Cambridge School
for young ladies in Cambridge
Massachusetts she was now in class
alongside and competing with girls you
could see in here Anne Sullivan attended
every class alongside Helen interpreting
the lessons Helen made rapid progress
completing her first year's study with
honors in German and English in her
second year however she struggled
especially with mathematics the decision
was made to withdraw her from the school
and provide her with a private tutor a
year later she was ready to take the
entrance exam for Radcliffe College the
women's division of Harvard University
passing with distinction she became the
first person with major disabilities to
enter an Institute of higher learning
Helen found the pace at Radcliffe
frantic again she had an alongside her
to spell out the lessons on her fingers
but even then she had difficulty keeping
pace with fast talking lecturers despite
the harried pace Helen did well
especially in English during her second
year a literacy teacher encouraged her
to write her life story so that the
world could get an insight into the
struggles that she had gone through
Helen worked on the manuscript while
studying which also placed an
intolerable strain on her finally in
March of 1903 the story of my life was
published sales were slow at first but
it has gone on to become a beloved
classic and was recognized by the New
York Public Library as one of the 100
most important books of the 20th century
indeed this was the first of 15 books
that she would go on to write Helen
graduated from Radcliffe on June the
28th 1904 to become the
first person with a serious disability
to earn an undergraduate degree she now
found herself in demand for speaking
engagements where people flocked to hear
her inspirational story in 1905 and
Sullivan married John Macy helped Helen
publish her autobiography the three of
them lived under the same roof with Macy
and Helen developing a very special bond
Helen devoted the rest of her life to
helping the blind she wrote extensively
on the subject and worked tirelessly for
a uniform system of Braille along with
them and sometimes her mother Kate she
traveled internationally giving lectures
and sold-out halls everywhere from
Canada to Australia when Ann died in
1936 former housemaid Polly Thompson
became Helens constant companion during
World War two Helen was a ray of hope
for the thousands of servicemen who were
blinded or deafened in combat during
1943 alone she visited 70 army and naval
hospitals up and down the United States
in her later years
Helen was widely regarded as the
greatest living American woman in 1964
she was awarded the Presidential Medal
of Freedom four years later she suffered
a heart attack
she died on June the 1st 1968 at her
home in Westport Connecticut she was 87
years of age so I really hope you
enjoyed that episode of biographic if
you did there's a couple of things you
could do right now one is hit that like
button below also if you want more stuff
like this we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday so hit
that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on YouTube if you actually want to
get a notification about these videos
please do hit that Bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send
you a notification every time every
Monday and Thursday we won't put out a
new video also if you want to watch
something else right now stuff from the
archive over there on the right and as
always thank you for watching